when i got to the simpsons i had just
been a pure sketch writer and was you
know young in my 20s and
was only interested in
something being really funny
um
didn't and and when i when people talked
about character development and you need
to care about these people
i thought it was [ __ ] i just thought
i don't i i just want to think of the
best mr burns joke i want to think of
the best homer joke i want to think of
the best
um
and
it was
jim brooks who really impressed on us
that
i know it's a cartoon but this is a
family and you have to believe that they
love each other and that they're
connected
and i when i first heard it i thought
what what are you talking about we don't
need that do we really need to do that
and i realized you know the show's been
on for i think 110 years now
and it's
yes the jokes are there but people also
believe in this family in a crazy way
even though it's a cartoon
and that to me is something that's all
through your book
um respecting these characters and i
think this comes from your
you know your theater background
and
understanding that you
people need to be invested they won't
come back week after week just for jokes
jokes are great but they have to be
rooted in who the character
is and
um
you know i used to i go back sometimes
and look at a mayberry
you know andy griffith show and i look
at the interplay between andy griffith
and don knotts
and think this is just
pure beautiful you know uh character
comedy
you know sometimes there isn't
necessarily a joke you're just laughing
at the fact that these two people are so
different and
we're watching them interact and you
also know that they care about each
other
i net and i understand that now at my
late age much better than i did when i
was a kid that that is what supports the
whole thing yeah you
the audience has to be invested in the
characters
uh they
you have to
you give them um
and you know you have to give them
something underneath that grounds the
characters
and uh
you know with cheers we we made salmon
ex-alcoholic
because that gave him although he's
you know he's a stud and wants to go to
bed with every woman he's still
underneath
there's a kind of sadness to him and he
blew his cr his career
so
that's you know that that's that's
important that's what grounds them
that's why where audiences identify with
them
you know with every character louis de
palma
you identify with him by his lot in life
by how he looks
you know he's angry
but you attribute it to
well
the hand he was dealt the same with
carla
you know with diane even with diane you
still
you know
she wanted to be
a professor but she was never going to
be a professor she was
she was going to be a waitress and
so that's what you know because people
real people identify with that you know
it's interesting because in the book you
point out and i hadn't thought about
this either which is that in uh and i
thought it was fascinating that
in your guys opinion
all these characters
have these flaws
have these um
inner conflicts they're constantly being
broken they're constantly being put back
together again
except for one norm
and you and you say norm is just the one
truly centered happy
uh character who's who sits who kind of
anchors the whole thing and i thought oh
yeah i see that now that i hadn't
thought of it quite that way yeah he's
well you know
he's uh he's happy just sitting on a
barstool
you know having saying one more for the
road and
never leaving in fact the only time the
only time uh we we addressed
uh designated driving was in the pilot
episode when coach
drives norm home because he's been there
too long but we we never did it again
norm is
norm is a character that everybody knows
yeah i had a norm at the allstate bar in
new york city
uh there was a guy who sat at the end of
the bar and just says and literally said
one more and i'm out of here and you
know at the end of the evening he was
still there and everybody knows norm
there's great
um some of the dialogue that you reprint
in here is
i said so great but just i was reading
through all these norm lines and they
are so um
so fantastic and there's one where he's
i think sam's closing up and
norm just says wow 17 and a half hours
just flew by
but there's so many great
pages of norm lines in here that are
that are fantastic it saves me writing
so uh
hey i noticed that yeah but the writer's
guild wants to talk to you by the way
the evolution
the evolution of the normism
i talk about in the book the evolution
of the normism is that
in the pilot
in front of the pilot audience
when norm entered
and says uh afternoon everybody and
everybody says norm because that was
from uh
nikki colisanto at a bar he was from
rhode island and in providence he had a
bar where everybody screamed his name
when he walked in right and sam said
what do you know and norm says not
enough and that was not written as a
joke
that was not written as a joke right and
when the audience roared
at that line
i looked at glenn and i looked at glenn
charles and i said you know and
i i looked at him with the look of
saying oh my god they're laughing at a
character yeah yeah this roly-poly guy
saying not enough
you know if you had another guy coming
and doing it it would not have been the
same as george doing it right and uh so
it became incumbent upon us every time
he entered
to do you know
to do a joke there was so many of them
like uh
sam pour me a beer it's 9 a.m float a
corn flake in it
oh there was this scene that i always
remembered and i was so glad you
reprinted it in here where a little boy
comes into the bar that's from the pilot
it's in the pilot and
and um
god the boy comes in how about a beer
chief and sam says uh how about an id
and the kid says an id that's very
flattering where do i tell the misses
and sam looks at the id and he goes ah
military id first sergeant walter keller
born in 1944 that makes you 38. must
have fought in vietnam boyce says oh
yeah sam says what was it like boy gross
sam yeah that's what they say war is
gross
and then he says i'm sorry soldier and
the boy goes this is the thanks we get
i mean
that's
that's the best
that's just a
best tv writing imaginable that's that's
how the pilot opens yeah it's such it's
so great i mean
it was original it was originally later
on in the show
but we moved it up and we we could do a
tag or a teaser so a teaser's before the
show tags at the end of the show so we
moved it up to be uh
uh the teaser and it was uh john naven
was the kid's name i'll never forget it
and teddy was so great yeah in that
scene yeah because he wasn't mean
he was sweet with the kid
tolerant and it it just set that
character uh he's yes ending the whole
time you know he's saying uh-huh okay
well let's take a look you know
very good first sergeant all right